you know judicial was invented for the
smaller guys yeah yeah yeah i mean i
don't know
he's going to write
when he did it to rampage his video
footage of me
carter got you in that triangle yeah
it's on my channel
i was different i was different at that
moment that's the only time i ever lost
my temper in the fight this is when you
take them up and slam there's a back
story behind if you watch that video and
you pause it right now
i come off the ground yes i remember
that it's not i lost myself
context he's fighting pride and this guy
ricardo arono who's a black belt got him
in a triangle trip and he
picks him up off the mat
jumps in there and goes
right here right here right here i
remember this well
you're not allowed to do this
but no one's ever seen it there's no
time
no one ever seen this yeah they try to
get it they're trying to it's like one
of the best knockouts in history
those guys try to get me like fine and
everything from it for this one
rampage why were you so mad here
uh i'm gonna show i'm gonna show up the
story he had did something to piss me
off he backed out of a fight when i got
to japan and i had to fight morillo
busamante
and no one told me about that he's a
monster and then when he was in that
right man right here he's he healed he
heals me in the face and he um
dislocates my jaw right damn so he's
like hitting him in the face so i go
down he tells the referee right there
yeah
he tells the referee i'm knocked out
right there and the pride referees hated
me yeah they could have caught that
fight and that's a tournament
you know so i could have lost that fight
because of that and that pissed me off
when he did that he told referee right
now your jaw's dislocated right now oh
yeah my dog dislocated at night
i remember this this changed a lot of
this i remember everybody was like
triangles don't work against some guys
if they're strong enough look what
rampage did this was crazy i remember if
you if you pause at the right time i
come off my feet i was really mad at
this guy because the representation they
used to always give me yellow cards they
cheated me when i fought vandalised
civil uh when i remember i fought that
tournament yeah this is gonna tell you
guys something when chuckledale came
over to pride
they had a meeting with me uh
the representative probably came and
said look chuckledale's coming over from
the ufc
and they said we made a bet with dan we
got a lot of money we got a lot of money
on this fight you need to uh [ __ ] chuck
liddell up i said yeah but you know i
got to fight vanilla silver next because
y'all gave vanilla silver some some judo
guy and my dumb ass i was young i told
him my gameplay all right i'm gonna do
this i'm gonna [ __ ] chuckle dale up but
when i fight vanilla i'm gonna have to
take him down and ground the pound is
it's gonna you know it's gonna be a
different fight yeah i'm a grounded
pound and i'm and i'm a [ __ ] you guys
go back and watch that fight when i i
took ventilate down ground pound like i
just had a [ __ ] war with chuck ledell
yeah 45 minutes before and i'm and i'm
beating up ventilating i told them my
game plan i'm beating them up on the
ground they give me a yellow car saying
i'm stalling
and i wasn't even stalling i was beating
them up
i was getting ready to knock them out
what's the why would they be there
and they wanted
he was a man over there and they wanted
vanilla to win they set the tournament
up for a ventilated win like so the guy
they fought vanderlaa was like they
called him the axe murderer he was like
he was crazy
dude legend especially when he fought
him they're both like yeah
yeah i wasn't i wasn't nothing back then
that's no i was i was coming up in pride
yeah i was coming up vanderlia was like
he was a man
he was he was a man back then and i was
i was dumb to tell them my game plan
because yeah you told me i told i told
you you know i was an experienced i
didn't know that they wanted vanilla to
win you didn't know that they didn't
have your best interest no i didn't know
that yeah and i shouldn't have told them
my game plan i should have told them
like [ __ ] yourself they're telling me to
go and take out on top of the day yeah
they they didn't tell me to beat them
they said [ __ ] them up
show the world that pride has the best
fighters because you remember uh
chuckledale had knocked out um
alex overing yeah and they was upset
about it with the overhand right yeah go
ran right yeah